ايوه
هذه قريه ابو هجب بمحليه المناجل وهذا ما
خلفته موجه السيول التي اجتاحتها قبل اشهر
ان لم يجد محمد عثمان سوا هذه الخيمه
لتكون ملجا له بعد انهيار منزلي
يتقاسم محمد وافراد اسرته ضيق المكاني
قسوه الطقس البارد
ما عندنا اي شيء قدامنا عشان نقدر
ما كنا
اما حسين فيصابق الزمن لبناء غرفه يحتمي
بها بعد ان من الانتظار الوعود بالتعويض
وواقع لم تغيب الاطفال ايذاء معاناه
يعيشونها منذ اكثر من سته اشهر وهم
يترقبون العوده الى مساكنه عيد الام
الخريف قرب
الناس لازم تعمل لها حاجه
لانه الرواتب جماعه عمليه للمطر
اكثر من 160 منزلا ينهار بشكل كلي ونحو
200 منزل انهار جزئيا في هذه القريه بحسب
احصاءات اللجان الخدمه المحليه
اما المدرسه الوحيده في قريه ابو هاجر
فتحولت الى خيام
من سته اصول ابتدائي مختلط
كل الفصول عدد الفصول فيها يعني 6 فصول
ومكتبان وحمام واحد على الصوره انهار
تماما الفصول الستي انهارت
الان احنا شغالين يعني اكيد
اضرار موجه السيول في ولايه الجزيره طالت
اكثر من 500 قريه في محليتي المناجل وجنوب
الجزيره بحسب احصاءات رسميه
وتحاول السلطات الحكوميه مع المنظمات
الانسانيه تدارك اثار الكارثه غير ان تلك
الجهود ما تزال بالنسبه للمتضررين من
السيول دون الحجم المطلوب